(lighthearted music)
- You know they don't tell
you, "Don't lay on the bed."
You're supposed to lay on the bed.
- [Narrator] If you've
ever visited an Ikea,
you've likely encountered
their store's endlessly
winding floor plan.
This layout can be confusing,
but that is by design.
Ikea may be the biggest
furniture retailer on the planet
but it's certainly not conventional.
The Swedish furniture
giant asks its customers
to build their own products
and it stores and
distributes those products
in minimalist flat packed boxes.
So, how have these retail strategies,
as well as their famous Swedish meatballs
contributed to the
company's runaway success?
This is the economics of Ikea,
a look at the innovative
business practices
that have transformed modern life.
- [Sarah] When you step into an Ikea,
you immediately sort of
are put into this maze like
path of different rooms.
- [Narrator] Ikea's store
layout is a fixed path design
which means there's a designated road
that all customers must follow
that guides you through
the store in one direction.
- [Sarah] It's not a grab a carton of milk
and get out kind of store,
it's the opposite of that.
It's very much set up to spend a day,
think about rooms you know,
dream about what you really want
your bedroom to look like.
- [Narrator] The floor
plan of most Ikea stores
resembles a maze that
curves about every 50 feet
to keep customers curious
about what comes next.
Since an average Ikea store
is around 300,000 square feet
or five American football fields,
that means a lot of walking.
- An Ikea is to some frustratingly winding
but really it's laid out as an experience
to get you to buy more.
(drill buzzing)
- [Narrator] Ikea is famous
for putting its customers to work.
Unlike most furniture retailers
that sell products preassembled,
many of Ikea's pieces
have to be built by their customers.
But why?
As many couples and their
therapists will know
building your own Ikea
cabinet can be challenging.
- The big idea behind the Ikea effect is
consumers are more attached
to have more positive feelings
towards objects or things
that we've put effort into.
And that we actually think
that they're more
valuable because of that.
- [Narrator] The term Ikea
effect was first coined in 2011
by researchers who noticed
a similar phenomena
in other products and businesses.
When instant cake mixes were
first introduced in the 1950s
they didn't sell well.
- And then they said,
"Let's add a fresh egg."
It was this idea that we wanna feel
like we're just participating
enough to not feel guilty
about taking a shortcut.
- [Man] When you make a cake
from a mix which do you want?
A fresh egg cake or a
cake made with dried eggs?
A higher, lighter, tastier
cake, why fresh eggs of course.
- The idea that we should
love building products
isn't necessarily what Ikea intended.
- [Narrator] If you've ever
shopped at one of Ikea's
massive warehouse stores
you're likely aware of the
unconventional product names
but what you may not realize
is that in creating these items
Ikea sometimes comes up
with the price tag first.
- So we have a classic
example that they could talk
about all the time is the $1 light bulb.
But they had this idea
that a $1 LED light bulb,
you know this new type of light bulb
would be hard to achieve,
but if they could achieve it,
lots of people would buy LED light bulbs.
So they just sort of designed backward
with the price point in mind.
- [Narrator] That
obsession with low prices
is a large part of why Ikea is the world's
largest furniture retailer.
Today, Ikea has 445 stores
operating in 52 countries.
- You know obviously if you
go into a student dorm room,
you're gonna find a lot of Ikea,
but you'll also find some Ikea products
in a wealthy person's home.
And that's really what they're going for.
- [Narrator] Today, Ikea
is the very definition
of mass market appeal, but
when the company first began
as a Swedish mail order business in 1943,
well-designed furniture
tended to be expensive.
And as a result out of reach for most,
or seen as a serious long-term investment.
Ingvar Kamprad, who founded
the company as a teenager,
pushed forward the idea that
furniture could be flat packed
to massively reduce the cost
of shipping and transportation.
- So flat packing is
really the largest arguably
Ikea invention that really
led to the company's growth.
And the idea is that
instead of buying, you know,
a piece of furniture I'll put
together, it's deconstructed
into a flat pack, where you
can fit more in a truck.
You can fit more in the Ikea warehouse
and you can also get it in your car.
And the trade-off is you know
you put it together at the end.
- [Narrator] Flat packing
is a practical aspect
of the philosophy that has
long guided Ikea's success
called democratic design.
- It's this idea that
everything is imbalanced
both price, form, function, the aesthetic,
the sustainability.
- [Narrator] This vision
to create a better everyday
life for the many people
was sent forth more than
30 years ago by Kamprad
in a manifesto now presented
to every Ikea employee.
- And they talk about
it almost religiously,
and fundamentally it's this idea
that when designing a
product they think about
it can't just be really cool looking,
it can't just be functional,
it has to be all of those things.
- [Narrator] So despite
the long shopping trips
and the DIY, customers can't
seem to get enough of Ikea.
Perhaps it's as simple
as labor leaves to love.
(lighthearted music)